wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
danke tag sehr sehr lecker freut mich
dass solch geschmeckt hat es ist schön
wieder hier zu sein ich hatte fast ein
bisschen heimweh du hast spanien
vermisst nein spanien ist mein
heimatland ich komme aus spanien
aber mein zuhause ist deutschland und
deutschland habe ich vermisst
ja das verstehe ich auch deutschland ist
mein zuhause
ich komme zwar aus der türkei aber ich
bin schon sehr lange hier
wie lange lebst du schon in deutschland
schon vor 30 jahren bekommen
ich bin vor 15 jahren als au pair
mädchen nach deutschland gekommen das
land war fremd die sprache auch ich
meine ich war froh ich wollte spanien
verlassen und in deutschland studieren
aber es war nicht immer leicht alles war
neu
ich hatte glück ich hatte hilfe es ist
wichtig dass man hilfe hat in so einer
situation
ich hatte meine freundin meine beste
freundin
vor fünf jahren ist sie in die schweiz
zurück gegangen vor ein paar wochen habe
ich einen anruf von sarah bekommen die
vaters gestorben
es war schlimm sie hat meine hilfe
gebraucht ich habe meine sachen gepackt
und bin nach zürich geflogen
woraus linnichs gesorgt und was ist mit
dir wie lange wird es eigentlich bleiben